never mind the doutters greece bounced
into its six-month presidency of the
european council with prime minister
antonis samaras promising to finance the
real economy especially supporting small
businesses outlining his country's chief
priorities to mep's mr samara spoke of
the need to balance fiscal discipline
and growth
some mep said greece's tough experiences
could serve well other causes you can
apply all the lessons you learn in
greece to reform the european union
you're in the best position to tell your
colleagues no don't do this please
do a banking union
consternation over malta's plan to offer
1800 passports and with them full eu
citizenship rights to anyone with a big
enough wallet at 650 000 euros per
passport they're not for those on a
tight budget but malta says it's not
inventing the wheel eight other member
states have similar schemes it's not
just as if anybody can apply and then
what will come in they're going to pass
from a very very tight sieve
um whoever applies to make sure that we
are not being used for money laundering
for crime
following the food scandal last year in
which horse meat was sold as more
expensive beef meps have agreed tough
new penalties to tackle fraud in the
food chain
steering this through parliament mep
esther de langa says food fraud is
increasing and that feeble fines and
weak cross-border controls encourage
criminals europa is invaded
she's calling for tougher sanctions
including withdrawal of licenses